welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 8 chapter
24 the season finale I'm gonna break
down all the Star Wars Easter eggs and
details you missed in this finale and
where everything's headed next in Ahsoka
subscribe to my new channel the Deep
dive where this Friday will be my
analysis of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and you can support this growing Network
by grabbing something from our merch
store nerd riot.shop like our 89p13
rocket science tea okay this finale
episode opens on Mandalore where ax woes
is blasting through storm clouds into
the upper atmosphere just getting
hammered with rain which I like to think
accounts for a metaphorical Living
Waters baptism because boy oh boy did X
wolves really prove us wrong with
anybody who thought he might have been
another spy no our man is a hero and
when he was plunging that light Cruiser
down on MAF Gideon's base he was totally
aiming for the bushes because
access communication with bocaton cuts
out a recurring issue on Mandalore this
season we thought because of storm
formations but in reality more likely a
signal emitted by moth Gideon's base to
keep his operation secret which is why
he only was able to bypass it with a
call to Elia Kane last episode bogoton
orders ax to use his capital ship as a
decoy which he does making its red
mythosar paint job a perfect Target in
retrospect but really it is ax's idea to
plunge Mark Gideon's former light
Cruiser back into the base making a
perfect circle to bring it in to moff
Gideon's insanity and I like to think of
this as ax whoops as holdo maneuver and
X X and Y ax bogoton and cascarries
escape the best guard Commandos by
detonate into charge mapoda is a pretty
cool move of the resting forward while
pivoting midair to get off a few Final
Shots against the Commandos by the way
this white bescar armor looks similar to
the non-beskar armor worn by the first
order Stormtroopers so maybe brindle hux
will rip off mob Gideon's designs but
use a cheaper material did Jordan breaks
free from custody and I love how they
mix in Olympic Games flute every time he
activates with a cool move
thanks
in general I just love the sound mixing
of the scene every punch in Block clings
with the sound of beskar against beskar
did jarian snatches the best guard blade
from the commando's boot and knowing
that it's made of bescar he uses it to
block a blaster ball from the other one
grogu riding in ig-12 saves him no no no
no no no no no
of course daiko tg's voice coming back
there and I just love that grogu is
using a free hand to smash that no
button over and over to scream at the
Commando grogu uses back to spray the
same healing fluid that's in the back to
tanks this was sprayed by ig-11 on din
Jaron in the season one finale that was
chapter 8 and brought back again to heal
Mando in chapter 5 in the book of boba
pet this finale is titled the return and
in addition to being the return for the
Mandalorian people to their home planet
finally rid of the curse of MAF Gideon
and the return of life to the planet
after centuries of Civil War it's also a
return to form for the series as a whole
back to those pre-dark saber days of a
Lone Wolf and Cub bird taking on
episodic Adventures many of us last week
definitely overthought chapter 23's
episode titled the spies to mean there
might have been another traitoris
Mandalorian working with mob Gideon and
Elia Kane someone like the armorer or ax
wolves but no and honestly it's a relief
to see these mandalorians working
together and not having to justify a
bizarre twist that would have
contradicted their actions up until now
but one interpretation that I really
liked a theme under current discussed by
my buddy Ryan Airy over at screen crush
and many others online is that the spies
of the title parallel the 12 Spies Moses
sent out to scout the land of Canaan to
find a new home for the Israelites in
the Old Testament at the start of the
season when we translated that book of
Exodus Easter egg on the tablet that was
found on Mandalore I speculated that din
jar and grogu and bogoton reflect
figures like Moses who led the
Israelites out of Egypt or Joshua
Moses's successor who led them to the
promised land those 40 years wandering
the desert were incredibly important
because they better inform us as we
suffer and stumble through our lives and
it was God's will that Moses's
generation died before Joshua could
enter the promised land so that the sins
of the past generation would be fully
wiped away Moses was an important leader
of course but he had to pay that price
and allow his descendants to inherit his
dreams as all parents and Elders must do
now one visual contrast I love this
episode is how bogoton's Mandalorian
Scouts escaped the caves interesting
upward followed immediately by a cut of
mop Gideon's Thai interceptors hanging
like bats dropping downward it sets up a
race to the capital ship that keeps the
tension up and Frames this episode
around an amazing aerial battle that's
just undeniably fun to watch moth Gideon
tracks didn't grogu through a map of his
base on the left orabesh translates to
East Wing in the upper middle that
served then ER room server room and then
to the right in smaller text that's
communication something that's probably
where he's sitting out this signal
jammer from didn't jar and radios to R5
to stomp into the base referring to the
scomp linking that he does later just
like R2D2 does on the death star and a
new hope I love R5's worried Psy
[Music]
and Mando responds sorry I don't speak
binary yes binary is the Indian verse
term for Droid speak that we hear spoken
by Astromech but I guess Mando
understands everything R5 says after
this just be a context as grogu follows
Mando notice he spins the ig-12 Droid
head around 360 Degrees using that IG
Droid capability to see behind his back
and in all directions R5 uses jet
thrusters like the ones urgent detoopers
showed up and attacked the clones and I
like how he first wields up to the edge
as if the poor guy might want to give
himself a chopper push but it's just to
nervously look over the edge because he
cannot help it from being the same red
Astromech with the busted motivator who
led to R2D2 going to Luke and Uncle Owen
I just love how important a path R5 has
been given ax was so smoothly lands on
that light Cruiser and doesn't break his
Sprint shouting at all the others to
clear the bridge and thank God because
when they land on those gauntlets and
those gauntlets drop below the cloud
layer the camera stays on the clouds and
it's literal seconds before the Thai
interceptors and bombers rise up through
IT director Rick vanuiwa and editors
Jeff sybinik and Rachel goodlet cats do
an amazing job intercutting rapidly
throughout this episode to elevate the
tension so that in moments like this
when we stay on the cloud layer for a
whole 17 seconds we understand how
critical all of that timing was Expos
rigs up the light Cruiser's cannons to
operate them from the captain's chair
basically doing all six parts of
Smugglers Run on your own good luck with
that but if you look closely he shoots
one TIE Interceptor swing as skew and we
follow that Interceptor from above as it
skids along the light Cruiser's hole
until its wing rips off and it rolls and
crashes right before the bridge the
crash shown from a mounted camera point
of view of the Interceptor in front of
it would have seen some great dog bite
cinematography here but my favorite
sequence of the episode is ninjar and
working his way through that barrier
Shield path these barrier Shields
looking like the ones that Darth Maul
and Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan fought through
on that boo and Phantom Menace but here
there are four levels and it's
structured kind of like a video game or
a literal Gauntlet challenge with each
level getting increasingly difficult
stage one Amanda relies on surprise to
steal one of their blades and he snaps
through the gaps of their armor then he
used the shield on the back of the first
Commando to block the Blaster shot and
then he flings the blade into the neck
but that guy drops down into hell so he
loses the knife at this point all the
Commandos see Mando coming so he's lost
the element of surprise and these next
Commandos have their prods ready but as
with the knife Mando uses the weapons he
steals from each stage to help him
through the next one so stage two Mando
ping pongs between them but like a
wrestler using elastic ropes to gain
momentum he uses that momentum to spring
forward and knee the first one in the
head on to stage three these commanders
saw how Amanda stole the pride so now
they have their Shields up Amanda is
able to prod one of them in the foot to
knock him down and then he snatches that
one's Blaster now during all this R5 is
spotted by a mouse droid who sounds a
siren it actually sounds like R5 says
but in that delayed time Mando has on
stage three the blastifier is producing
so much smoke that it creates a literal
smoke screen and when that fourth Shield
opens stage four Mando has regained the
element of surprise and he slides past
them to grab the Blaster and uses these
two Commandos shocked that one man could
bring down a full hallway of them to
confirm their greatest fears so with all
these stages cleared notice how Mando
has red light from above looking just
like that red light that is reflected on
his chrome dome in the opening loose
film Fanfare of every episode this
season and then R5 now swarmed by Mouse
droids jets away knocking one of them
off the ledge as he departs so they
enter this tank room that we saw last
episode and we learned that the shadowy
figures that MAF Gideon passed are not
snoke strand casts but rather clones of
MAF Gideon himself which is why last
episode he said and the most impressive
Improvement
is that it has me in it this is that all
of MAF Gideon's side cloning research
with Dr Pershing notes that he did not
share with brindle hooks with full
transparency was really mob Gideon's
attempt to subvert hux's side of the
business project Necromancer which of
course is tickle and Palpatine so that
MAF Gideon could create these four
sensitive clones of himself so this may
dispel the thinking that grogu's DNA
will directly lead to snoke in the
Palpatine clones of the sequel Trilogy
then again last week Gideon told Huck
said pershing's cloning research was
lost for now so I assume that Eli Kane
may now report to hux and that knowledge
will continue to serve the first order
even if grogu's DNA is no longer in the
mix but important to note when we saw
moff Gideon in season 1 and season 2 he
had a mustache whereas this season he's
been clean shaven along with all of his
clones so who knows the MAF Gideon who
dies this episode might not even be the
original Gideon uh that's the thing
about clones somehow they'll always
return I'm a big fan of being my best
self and Beyond failing my brain with
fun things to think about dogs wearing
pants hamsters and top hats you know the
usual stuff I also like to take care of
my body and if you like taking care of
your body You're Gonna Want To fully
tune in because we are going to have one
of the best offers we've ever given on
this channel thanks to geology geology
is an 18-time award-winning skin hair
and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ geology creates
simple and effective skin care and Hair
Care routines customized just for you
with ingredients that are proven to work
their products are built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs geology has got you
covered no matter how you're looking to
up your personal care game but right now
they are offering a special offer for a
skin care sampler pack which is great
because their skin care stuff rules
geology's line of skincare products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles and combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging
personally I'm a fan of their vitamin C
plus e fioric acid serum but I use
everything else geology has co-wash for
your hair body wash for your body and
deodorant for your odors whatever you
need gelsey has you covered there's
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a limited time to use
code new Rockstar's 100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30 day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping this is hands down the best
deal that is out there and on top of
that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off on
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to
geolog.ie
rockstars100 to get started the
Mandalorian survivors played by Charles
Parnell that's warlock from Top Gun
Maverick and Charles Baker that skinny
Pete from Breaking Bad take them to this
Refuge cave filled with regrown plant
life these are the old species
indigenous the Mandalore they've been
dormant since before the centuries of
Civil War he's referring to the long
history of Mandalorian civil wars that
took place on the planet before the
Clone Wars one of the most recent ones
referenced in chapter 14 by Boba Fett
your father was a foundling he even
fought in the Mandalorian Civil Wars
external and internal stripe reduced
Mandalore to the barren desert as part
of the Mandalorian cataclysm leading to
their Dome cities like Dari so this is a
version of Mandalore that even Bo Katan
would be unfamiliar with the Survivor
Captain says once the planet was
abandoned they sprouted in spots we
cultivated Farms
life persists so I think this is the 40
years in the desert of The Exodus
parallel in episode one mandalorians as
a people are warriors by Nature they did
this to their own planet and so to heal
it they all have to leave this promised
land and serve a generation in Exile
before they're allowed to return to the
promised land renewed also this line
life persists seems like a Star Wars
version of Life uh
finds a way the armorer leads the
reinforcements to rejoin Boca time the
Armor's tongs are at her side though she
didn't seem to have them when she jumped
out of the gauntlet or whatever and
bogoton ignites the darksaber to lead
the charge the Mandos and Commandos
Collide and we stay with one Commando
who looks around completely confused
until the armor slams into him with her
hammer in tongs it's so great and it's
followed by a shot of bocaton in the
armor side by side bocaton slashing down
with the dark saber while the armor bats
went down with their tools it's like
we're seeing the power of the darksaber
aligned with the tools of the
mandalorians so that the tools of the
mandalorians are all that will matter
from here forward but either way they
are both together using the weight of
mandalore's gravity with their descent
to empower these attacks Gideon rages at
Mando for smothering his clone babies
said he didn't really try that hard in
the band and the two fight I actually
wouldn't be surprised if the stunt
actors who together play din jarin
Lateef Crowder and Brennan Wayne were
the ones in the suits for these scenes
because they're the same height and just
be perfect to end the season letting
these two go at it like this Gideon
unleashes his praetorian guards Grogan
marches in with the angriest face I've
ever seen him have no no so girl has to
briefly handle them by himself but he
Giggles as he Force leaps along the
light rigging and notice how throughout
this episode grogu never uses the force
as a weapon he only uses it to block to
defend to swipe weapons away this would
be a trait taught to him by Luke
Skywalker in a trait tied to Luke
Skywalker by Master Yoda but only after
the Jedi Order had fallen because in
Revenge of the Sith Yoda was killing
plenty of Clone Troopers bocaton tackles
Gideon to save dentjarn and free him up
to help grogu now these two face off and
as Gideon ignites his staff Pokemon
ignites a darksaber and angles it toward
him not enough anytime you can see the
flatness and the broken nature of the
blade reminded of the darksaber is an
anomaly among the other lightsabers
which are more cylindrical and pole-like
this is a flat blade and it's a cracked
aberration that is not meant to be long
for this universe as the praetorian
guards closing on grogu we see his
little head and pointed ears in the
foreground mirroring our very first shot
of the child in the pilot episode of the
series when Amanda first saw him in that
bassinet this is when he is at his most
vulnerable but with Den jarin's
offensive strikes and grogu's defensive
blocks they're able to defeat these
three praetorian guards between this and
The Last Jedi it's clear that you really
just need a parable Duo whenever you run
into these guys meanwhile Gideon crushes
the darksaber similar to Rey and kylo
splitting the lightsaber in The Last
Jedi ripping in half because they both
wanted it equally here both Gideon and
bogoton are squeezing that darksaber
handle so hard out of a similar
unyielding desire now yeah it does feel
a bit wrong that a supercharged grip
could break into an ancestral weapon but
it's also a cursed Relic that has only
brought pain to this world bocaton
doesn't need it to lead to me it's
broken appearance has always given it
some fragility it's always looked more
like a ghastly corpse on his last leg so
I don't mind seeing it Go ax woes
crashes into the base an open crack
remember formed by mob Gideon's Fusion
bombs during that night of thousand
tiers making this plus this being
Gideon's own poetic justice for how
moth Gideon dies it's like poetry it
Rhymes also yeah being caught in a fiery
explosion is exactly how Esposito's
character gets it in Breaking Bad grogu
saves them from the fire with a force
bubble as music plays a dramatic swell
of grogu's reunion music that we heard
when he and did jar and reunited on
between the book above a bit
[Music]
this earlier this melody sounds very
similar to Stephen Schwartz's power of
God music in The Prince of Egypt
[Music]
our little Moses here instead of parting
the Red Sea is miraculously manipulating
nature in a similar way with fire saving
them in a similar move to Kanan jairus's
sacrifice save and Rebels so we Circle
back to the opening scene of the season
the Mandalorian baptism ritual or Ragnar
Vizsla it was anorexic before now
completed in the Living Waters thank God
the Ferocious Beast at the bottom of
these Waters didn't come up to
interrupted here all the Mandalorian
houses are represented by their banners
on the far left the branched with the
red plumage of house vizla and on the
far right the animal face in White on a
red banner of house Eldar there's also a
ring-shaped Sigil on a yellow Banner
towards left side that kind of looks
like the Crusader sigil whereas before
this chamber was shrouded in darkness
that no one could see on Disney plus now
it's lit with lanterns gone from ruins
to a proper Temple despite customarily
going helmets off everywhere bogoton and
the night owls watch his ceremony
respectfully with their helmets on
Ragnar completes baptism in danger and
presents grogu to be added to the song
but since gruhu cannot speak dinjiran
adopts grogu as his son so that he can
be his Mandalorian Apprentice named din
grogu grogu looks down into the water
whereas before it was dark and murky now
it is illuminated and clear as the
clouds have lifted over Mandalore and
its depths are no longer threatening but
a source of inspiration Goku connects
with the mythosar setting up a possible
future where these two can meet the
smallest Mandalorian and the biggest one
bogoton reignites the great Forge using
a torch handed to her by the armor a
torch that it might just be me but it
looks like it might have been made from
the handle to the broken darksaber which
would be perfect because formerly a
weapon brandished to declare rule over
mandalorians now a beacon of light to
spark their eternal flame of a new
generation and overall this Forge looks
like it has four big columns cylindrical
almost like giant lightsabers with kyber
crystals burning from the middle but
hear an instrument of growth instead of
an instrument of division and death
Ginger and grogu returned to the new
Republic Pilot bar where once again it's
filled with Easter eggs that Billiards
type game that was in the Toshi station
in the New Hope deleted scene the same
location as the book of Boba Fett
there's various trophies of helmets of
Stormtroopers Scout Troopers Imperial
Pilots are a set of protocol Droid heads
ahead of an imperial probe Droid and now
in the far Corner an IG assassin draw
right head Misty Rose's plays a
bartender she played kuil in season one
and Dave filoni himself with his hat
returns as the X-Wing pilot Trapper wolf
I'm pretty sure Dave is saying random
Star Wars stuff in the background that
they kept in because asgrowku sits on
the stool you could definitely hear him
say PLO
Jedi Master plokun is obviously super
important to felony he's the one who
trained to sokotano at a young age he
was a great pilot plokoon was a cover
story for Luke Skywalker's cameo in the
season 2 finale and a blue mask
showed up as an Easter egg in Andor
Commando tells Carson Teva that he's up
to work contract gigs to help him Patrol
the outer rim setting up the episodic
Adventures that they'll go on in season
four and he asks his payment the IG
Droid head because since they stopped
manufacturing this this would be one
source of the chip that they need to
repair ig-11 which is what Amanda does
when he returns to Navarro get some help
from those anzelans and resurrex ig-11
as Marshall of Navarro that was the job
Greek cargo asked Meadow to do at the
start of the season and ig11 has red
plating matching grief's robes and the
pleading of axwell's redesign of the
ship the episode ends on Den jaren's new
Homestead a tree in a pond in the front
yard as grogu levitates a frog as he did
with Luke Skywalker in the book of Boba
Fett chapter 6. he does not eat the Frog
though he just plays with it our final
shot is a lucasfilmi iris out edit
framing this Father and Son together in
a little bubble if the Mandalorian wants
to move on from these characters as a
vocal ones and instead bring them in
every once in a while this would be a
fitting final shot for them but I think
it's important that we see a tree here
because trees are super important not
just to the Jedi religion but to all
religions when I say Jedi I'm not
talking about the way their Creed got
bastardized and politicized over the
years but the more natural approach that
ultimately has more in common really
with the Mandalorian Creed there's a
force tree that was in the Jedi Temple
on Coruscant we should also recognize
that there was a sacred gaffy tree to
the religion of the tuscans in the book
of Boba Fett all these religions I think
are different interpretations of the
same thing and just as Mandalore has
been restored with miraculous plant life
life interestingly has also found a way
on these lava Flats thank you for
joining us this season of the
Mandalorian you can subscribe to Deep
dive NR for deeper analyzes in the
titles you love you can support our
growing Network by grabbing something
from our merch store nerd riot.shop
subscribe to new rockstars on YouTube
and on all social platforms follow me at
eavos thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign